be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
what's going on comic nation this is Rob
and as we get closer to the u.s. release
of Avengers 2 you age of Ultron I
thought about me a good idea to take
some time away from time runs out and
explain the background of the Avengers
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe since
this is something that we haven't really
done yet now what I'm hoping this will
do is serve the purpose of explaining
each of these characters to give you an
idea of what's been going on behind the
scenes of the film's ultimately leading
up to the current events in Avengers age
of Ultron so Natasha Romanoff was born
on November 22nd in 1984 in Stalingrad
Russia now this information comes from
her shield file which also tells us that
her parents are unknown but they're
presumed deceased now the reason for her
shrouded background seems largely to be
tied to her earlier introduction into
the Black Widow program now the Black
Widow program was actually hinted at by
Natasha Romanov during her encounter
with Bruce Banner during the Avengers
film when she had mentioned that she had
been trained at a very young age in
terms of how to be an assassin but the
Black Widow program was actually
expanded on a little bit further with
regards to the Red Room program in the
TV show agent Carter when it was
revealed that Dottie Underwood was
actually part of the program that was a
precursor to the Black Widow program
again this was the Red Room this is
basically where they took younger people
and they taught them what they needed to
know to become assassins for the Russian
government now what we don't know is
exactly what kind of regimen Natasha
Romanoff was made to endure as part of
the Black Widow program but what we do
know is that once she graduated from the
program well I guess you could call it a
graduation of sorts so you had basically
gone on to become one of them one of the
foremost assassins I guess in the world
overall now in the Avengers film what we
actually get is this explanation I guess
in terms of the conversation between
Black Widow and Hawkeye with regards to
how it was a Black Widow and Hawkeye had
first met and what we learn is that
somewhere along the line after Black
Widow had become an assassin for the
Russian government she was targeted by
shield and that in response shield had
sent Hawkeye to assassinate Black Widow
but what had happened here is that
ultimately Hawkeye chose not to kill her
each owes to basically keep track keep
tabs on her to follow her to learn what
she was about and ultimately discovered
what her ID
he was now what this seems to do is lead
to this kind of friendship and possible
romantic interest between the two of
them we're not really sure how deep that
goes but this really kind of began the
introduction of her character and to
shield now we don't exactly know how it
was that she had eventually joined
shield we just simply know she was part
of shield one day but what we also
learned is that in the Winter Soldier
film if you guys recall she had been
talking to Captain America about the
Winter Soldier and what she had told us
is that when she was part of shield one
of her first major assignments was to
track her I guess a track and to
basically keep safe and Iranian nuclear
scientist but the result was that the
scientist had been shot by Bucky Barnes
by shooting through her and ultimately
the scientist was killed now this is
basically I guess the events that led up
into her becoming I guess a full SHIELD
agent but the next thing that we found
after this I guess after this particular
action was her introduction into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe proper with
Iron Man 2 now what's really interesting
here is that the way that she came about
introducing herself to Tony Stark was
actually due to a combination of her
being hired into Stark Industries as I
guess is Natalie rushman a I guess an
intern of sorts but also due to some
training or I guess I'm acting on her
behalf what had happened here is that
when one of her co-workers a woman by
the name of Samantha Carlisle had been
assigned to deliver various documents to
Pepper Potts and Tony Stark Natalie
rushman had actually used some pills to
knock Samantha unconscious and when she
did she took the documents herself and
delivered them to Tony Stark ultimately
resulting in her introduction in Iron
Man 2 and Tony Stark picking her up I
guess as a personal assistant of sorts
between Tony Stark and Pepper Potts now
following the events of Iron Man 2 the
Black Widow was actually part of the
events that unfolded in the Incredible
Hulk film now this was like how a book
tie-in what this told us is that her
role was largely a backup role that what
had happened was she had been assigned
by shield to I guess to travel at Culver
University and to keep tabs on Bruce
Banner when it was discovered by shield
that Bruce Banner had returned to the
United States but when the conflict
broke out between abomination and The
Incredible Hulk
Black Widow had been assigned as part of
the cleanup crew so to speak in the
sense that her
was to make sure that there was no
evidence of any kind that could be left
over that individuals could use to try
to copy the actions of Bruce Banner now
during this time she had encountered dr.
Samuel Sterns but of course she had
incapacitated him quite readily and then
of course transitioned on to the to the
next task and so what we found was that
right before the events of Avengers that
she had been tasked I guess to follow a
Russian general named Georgie Lucca I
think his name was and that of course as
we saw at the beginning of the Avengers
film she had allowed herself to be
captured and the result or I guess the
goal here was to basically learn
everything she could about Georgie Lucas
actions and then turn him over to shield
which of course she was successful in
doing now moving into the events leading
up to the Winter Soldier what we learn
is that right after the Battle of New
York happened that is to say The
Avengers film that when it ended that
Natasha Romanov had been partnered with
Steve Rogers now the first mission the
two of them had came in the form of an
attempt to follow the plans of a man
named Baker now we're not really given
anything other than the name Baker we
don't really know anything about him
but what we know is that Baker's goal
was to detonate or I guess to set off a
weapon called the zodiac
now the zodiac was a chemical weapon
that was also mentioned during agent
Carter during the one-shot and so what
we know is that somewhere along the line
this zodiac biological weapon had gone
into the hands of the strategic science
reserve which again was the precursor to
shield and that somewhere along the line
shield had basically lost this object
maybe it had been sold maybe an event
misplaced we're not really sure how this
happened
but it had ended up in the hands of
Baker now what we found was that Black
Widow Captain America and Brock rumlow
were ultimately successful in being able
to end Baker's campaign to set off this
this biological weapon and so the result
was that Baker was taken into custody
which of course led us into Captain
America the Winter Soldier and
ultimately the current events with
Avengers age of Ultron with that being
said I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did let me know and let me know
down in the comments section if you guys
want me to continue this series or if
you guys don't really want to see it any
more so
with that being said we'll catch you
guys later peace
you